oh gosh i wish you could feel the energy
in this room maybe you can
i have had so much fun with all of you
guys today
let's kick it over to our virtual
friends and family our vffs maybe
someone's got a question for me
i hear what jessica does hey
oh look at your little one i know
he's cozy this morning and that's our
question so
we like to be cozy it's fall in ohio i
like to have the windows open with the
breeze
and blankets but my husband would rather
just turn on the heat
um so he can be more comfortable and not
be so chilly
how can you help us with the thermostat
war um well
maybe instead of the thermostat war um
because i love ohio and you guys have
you know a range of weathers
maybe you guys could blanket and cozy
and extra pjs and sort of do like a
fabriced version of a sleep number
situation
you know like you can strip down
and he can bundle up and then you guys
can sort of
meet in that pretty little middle but i
feel your dilemma look at look
they've made mattresses two different
ways because people
do have different preferences and that's
okay
but i can actually sidebar with you and
talk about like
accoutrements and outfits and things to
help with
well i appreciate that thank you jessica
thank you
thank you for your question you know
what i think there might be another
jessica who has a question
two two two jessica's jessica are you
there
hello oh she's on her way oh from
vancouver
yes
[Applause]
what's your private yes i've got a
question um i get seasonal dry
lips do you have a remedy for that i am
so glad you asked because my
dermatologist who's renowned
and incredible and we can all benefit
from her wisdom dr
dan's cordy bomb i had never heard about
this product it completely changed my
life
and it will change yours we'll have it
on the website
in uh drew's picks i think that's the
section
so but i am going to personally send you
some jessica
thank you everyone love you vfs